we just looked at was this thing called
the Whispering Gallery and there are
whispering colors all over the world
they have they have been you know I was
gonna say architecture designs maybe
they've been designed for this exact
purpose and you saw a pretty vibrant I
wonder if you would draw with me right
it looks so big much like that right
roughly and you've got this president's
enter your meeting and another person
stating everything right now we know the
way sound usually what's with regard to
distance okay
the further away you are the less than
here now by the way just physically
speaking he actually mentioned it in the
solid and a few quarters by bravely
physically speaking why is that happened
well maybe I should take back my name is
why is it
that's something further away like for
it is starting the beginning to when I
see you guys right now
you look as bright to me as you would if
I saw you will never be this way so why
is it that when I speak to you now
versus if I see 200 meters way you can
hug me my voice why is only yes
the air particles and there's like no
space between
yeah good ok so it's actually a better I
played a bit of a trip on you in that
actually what does exactly the same
thing it's just over a much bigger scale
but the concept is the same that you
know sound is going up like this right
from a source okay but because as it
goes if you want to be better this way
it gets less and less dense because it's
the cover more space as it as it sort of
radiates out right so what actually
arrives at your gear is what is less of
it right so that's why we can see that
it's nice but I wonder if you saw that
little animation of what happens here
when they either side there was very
gallery right because all those sounds
are going out but rather than going out
and dissipating as we were just
describing that are dissipated all right
they do this weird reflectively
when all the sounds which from my voice
my mouth like going in all directions
they get so channeled towards one point
okay now this is a really fantastic
phenomenal I actually do a mentality of
any kind in Australia if you guys could
wake up and find out we should go visit
one but when you hear it like I don't
know if you had the first time they went
and stood in their quarters and he's
like eqqui be right and the other guy
says yes I could hear you like that
whisper that you hear is him the other
way facing the opposite direction
demonstrating is principle okay poor
Truman I was talking I promise right
about things that are related even it
seemed like all obviously those things
are technique I want you to look at this
pattern of reflection does this not seem
a bit familiar
if we don't looked at a shape kid recent
times that does something kind of like
this
for and then
okay all right suitable one actually you
would know because you all see the
cushion about rainbows right number one
that you will get a circle and you won't
have a knock over here that's intense
court and so on okay every angle that is
standing on this odd it traces out its
obtains the same angle the circumference
that's the first thing that I noticed
that you've got this like it even looks
like the same kind of cap that's number
one there's another kind of shape you've
been looking at it does a similar thing
this is that reflecting things right big
because Jen the parabolic reflector do
you remember this experiment in SP the
professionals and I make a point to say
that when you've got a parabola wherever
it is there is a point such that if you
for example with what you choose is
licensed under center if you send in
things like this right and so what does
all of those lines are perpendicular to
the directrix which is implied W
provided that direction every single one
of those lines is going to do what it's
it's going to reflect and it's gonna all
that every single thing is gonna come
back to you so they're gonna do things
like this it's gonna bounce back bounce
across you get the idea and we did we
did the proof for this even when we
talked out my angular incidents in
angular reflection blah blah so in other
words you'll get this before convert
second one you'll get this convergence
of so things that are going in other
places and they will come to a single
point now what you look at 1 2 3 these
shapes you actually probably don't even
necessarily know what this shape is but
you sort of do this shape and the circle
and grab Allah they are just like the
path of the Sun and the vibration of
guitar string and all of those little
atoms at the end
they are deeply deeply connected and I
don't what you tell you just reacts what
the connection is but hopefully that is
something's going on here
right something that's tourism so the
way we're going to enter into this like
mathematically few things that objects
that you know is we're gonna start over
in this matter we're gonna start with
the parabola because in terms of
understanding all this it's what we most
familiar with it's what we did a lot of
work with so do a little something which
is review the locus of the product
okay
yeah but what this of a parabola we
define with two pieces of information
right rather than giving me an equation
of y equals x squared blah blah blah
blah we say okay give me and you already
talked about the two piece of
information when you describe this
phonology one of the two geometric
pieces of efficient to find a parabola
potatoes number one focus and number two
the directrix okay so just to get our
heads back to this space could spin a
while we could vary calculus very
recently let's pick an easy focus and an
easy directrix and let's just you know
remember how do we get the equation of a
parabola that obeys you know those
measurements so here for example we
usually call a figures s if you recall
but will be a nice easy Sieber I'm gonna
go to the 0 now what is a nice value
okay but it's actually very small and if
you recall it's going to it's gonna pick
some that Lance like it's okay before I
before isn't really okay where would be
a nice convenient place to put the
directrix
like y equals how about negative for
again I'm trying to make things nice and
simple right and you can publicly
picture it now I heard from your head
where is the vertex so this is probably
going to be it's gonna be the origin
okay now let's prove that let's
demonstrate if I've got this and I've
got this the whole idea of luck is is
that you've got a point and it wriggles
around or traces out a pop right so
since it moves we call it X Y because
it's variable and then to get this ball
wrong we say the distance to the focus
and the distance to the directrix are
equal equal right so we're at PS equals
50 they don't have to disempower drop we
need to quids distance and then we need
the particular distance for me I'll give
you a minute can you just do that get
down to the end of your equation will
you do that point
I can't get something so we have
equation we have verify what we're
expecting for falls mainly that this is
gonna pass through the origin and so
happy times okay now now here's where
everything starts to get a very
suspicious we are saying that this is
somehow connected to these objects how
can we try to tease out what's going on
okay and the way we're going to do this
is a wonder if you see just have you
look at these objects right
the difference between these is the
difference of proportion right do you
see for instance just looking at these
two this almost looks like kind of a
stretched out version of this the
southern notice that like a kind of and
that's the shape for that one okay over
here it's almost like I stretched it so
much that it's kind of like working on
one side it's like put it down they take
as we know it never come back to close
okay so what I think proportion
proportionality right this process that
we went through in terms of getting the
equation of the Bacchus has a
proportional action has multiple
proportions but has one particular
proportion that is hiding there that's
been a human in plain sight right it's
hidden because when I asked you what do
we do thought this having put all
together you told me this correctly you
said these two distances are the same
that means there's a proportion between
these two differences distances right
the proportion is one-to-one or I could
just say one right so once you take this
line go back to everything and I want
you to write it like so
now it seems like we're happy that I'm
in the middle right all I've done is
uppers sorry
that's one you know I've divided all
that done is I've divided both sides by
PD right but now what you see is that to
get the parabolas what I want is the
proportionality between these things
should be identical right I want them to
be equivalent what happens if I don't
get different portions right this is our
skinny madness what if we tried
what if we tried proportion like a half
what would happen what would happen to
our ensuing equation and what kind of
locusts would we trace out if instead of
being you know an equal distance what if
this distance was twice like for this
distance now algebraically you can still
do this
would you get out you can give impact
instead of starting here I want to try
starting here and see what ends up
happened to yahuveh